hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
please make sure you subscribe that way
you get the episodes as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is
are you garbage it sure is baby little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that if they grow
up to be classy
they're just a big old piece of trash
take five
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a glorious day down here at antony's
basement
we're back here in new york city after a
week or running around the south
we couldn't be happier we're going to
talk about it a little bit
but my co-host is coming at you from
across the table at me
he's got the uh he's got the chase
corporate card so i call him mr ryan
sure
you folks know him as kippy but his mama
named him
kevin james hey gang what's up happy to
be here thanks for
[ __ ] tuning in the kids are coming
off a hot weekend thanks for tuning in
and
showing up thank you you saved us from
looking like a couple of bozos down
south gang
uh as always please make sure you rate
if you subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers
are true the roof true true to roof as
well as patreon.com those numbers are
also true to [ __ ] roof
uh go to patreon.com you can sign up to
get bonus episodes of ru garbage
you get episodes of hard feelings which
is me and foley [ __ ]
you know yeah having a good time a
little behind the curtains some hr we do
four those a month you get four of them
a month yeah which is a dollar fifteen
episodes we do those weekly and then uh
uh every month at the end of every month
we'll do an ayg livestream where we play
with our top two tier members which is
coming up we're going to have a nice fun
one
listen if you're in and you're not sure
they're a good time
we have a couple of beers everybody's
drinking we're asking you guys questions
you're asking us
questions we also it's a it's a it's a
it's an eclectic bunch we got in there
too love the [ __ ] out of them
but there's some wacko it's a good time
there are kinds of people
and one one i guess relatively normal
guy
crept in the first time because at the
end he goes i don't know what the [ __ ]
this is all about but it's a good time
he had like a business suit on that
sounds fantastic guys thank you so much
we [ __ ] love you and we're back baby
we love you and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
a lot of people don't know and um when
he's not producing the show
he's an absolutely fantastic [ __ ]
stand-up kid's got some chops
we love him he also likes to go and
watch uh
indie rock bands that are on independent
labels sure what he calls
his homies tell me he's a big homie guy
and also too
he has the large intestine of a north
american grizzly bear
and he likes to rip jewels in the back
of uh domestic flights
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen hey stinky
man oh man i lost the security deposit
on the airbnb because
for a little package i don't know what's
going on in there you look at that
that's like one of those sushi conveyor
belts that goes around
but they just never replace the sushi
kids sour
i cannot believe you're calling me
stinky you ripped a fart in nashville
that was like a gas leak i think it was
outside too
the neighbors had to evacuate it was
unbelievable the fire truck
showed up it was crazy never mind it's
just fully we're good
the paint was peeling off outside of
zany you didn't clear a room you cleared
a house and a yard yeah
yeah you two are animals to be honest
with you i
on the other hand i'm a gentleman that's
true that's true yes you are sir
[Laughter]
i had my little shoes off on the porch
at nashville get fully gotta look at my
oh my god folks we're going to post a
picture on patreon
oh i don't know he's all right with it
man these things i've never seen
a toe this long in my life they're big
i've never seen some penises aren't as
long as this guy's
i don't think my penis is as long as his
big toe he's got some [ __ ] gangly
gangly extremities man yeah man
[ __ ] play piano with those things
tickle the ivories
gang if you haven't guys you can't tell
by now this is a family episode
oh you're right this is just us it's
just you we thought
coming back from a long trip you know
the best thing to do
circled you act like it was like the
oregon trail we were gone for 48 hours
back from a long trip wasn't even a
weekend was there an actual oregon trail
or was that just a video game
well it was there was a i'm sure it was
based on uh you know
i know the donner party i don't know if
they were on the oregon trail
they ate each other in the woods
somewhere
no maybe maybe that was atari before you
guys started i don't know
i was a big orange oregon trail guy so
we're going to get to we're going to
answer you guys questions yes you know
if you sign up on patreon you get your
question answered on the air
but before we do that we're saving most
of the discussion of the trip okay from
the first part of the tour
if you don't know we're on tour right
now we're going to be going back out in
june
got a lot of dates coming up make sure
you check it out atlantic city june 18th
next day
that's gonna [ __ ] sell that's gonna
sell out we just got the numbers it's
[ __ ]
creeping yeah it's it's close so get
them now so make a move
all right it's going to be fun but we're
going to talk about the trip and his
toes and his gas and [ __ ] me and
chicken sandwiches
and the great time that we had on a hard
feeling that's a hard feeling zach but
before we but before we get to the
episode we just want to say
to raleigh to nashville to all the
[ __ ] fans that came out
that that came out that you know we got
we were able to get pics with
that brought us [ __ ] t-shirts that
brought us bobble heads
we [ __ ] love you guys yeah guys we
love you it was unbelievable
we didn't know if it was all gonna work
we didn't know if playing
are you garbage with the audience at the
end of the show was gonna work oh it's a
[ __ ] glance
good night yeah that's a [ __ ] way to
close the show good night
uh oh that's just fire that [ __ ] was
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] was something else you guys
are [ __ ] hysterical
i want to say that your questions were
unbelievable we had such a fun time
we want to say thank you yeah guys thank
you so [ __ ] much it was
uh a surreal [ __ ] two three days
whatever was
uh like we were speechless me and the
big man
before we got on the plane we shared a
hug and a cry it was a [ __ ] we were i
think he's close right now to be honest
with you no i'm good
um just don't mention schultz you start
talking about shots i'm gonna get all
teary-eyed
no it was uh it was a surreal moment
[ __ ]
10 years of getting kicked in the dick
kicked in the dick [ __ ] go down to
raleigh and nashville and have people
come out and [ __ ] meet everybody and
[ __ ] hug and [ __ ] making out with
each other
we [ __ ] picked us there was a there
was one couple that came up to us
an hour and a half before raleigh they
got there or they came from out of town
they got there early i mean fuller out
out front catching a couple of bone
bernies a couple of bernies
in there setting up the cameras doing
what t-bone does and they come up
they're like hey guys can we just ask
you know
is it out of hand or whatever or you
know is that a line if we ask you for a
picture real quick and we were like
fuzzy you're our first [ __ ] fans i
thought they were going to tell us not
to smoke in front of the building
you ain't from around here are you born
that's where my self-esteem is at
but not after this but they were like
hey listen we did we're huge fans we
want to take pics and we were like i'll
[ __ ] yeah like this is i want to take
pictures with you guys
we love you can we get pictures of you
yeah we love you so then they were like
they were like listen we're going to go
around the corner and really geek out
after this i'm like we're going to go
back in the green room
and [ __ ] ball tap each other like
little school boys we were [ __ ]
giddy fantastic it was an awesome trip
thank you so much and we can't wait to
meet everybody else out on the road and
i'm telling you
get these pics live shows i don't like
to to my own horn
no but you know these high shows are
[ __ ] something else first at bat put
that [ __ ] in the [ __ ] parking
lot
yeah yeah yeah it was [ __ ] it was a
great time i [ __ ] love every single
one of you i can't
can't wait to meet everybody it's a
[ __ ] you guys are the best all right
enough of the [ __ ] uh
now back to business back to the trash
we got some psycho questions here that
we got to get to kippy forgot his
computer by that yeah i feel naked by
the way i'm just gonna do this
uh also by the way i forget whose
question it was but it was if you have a
if you have a flip case on your phone
you're trash which i feel those aren't
a direct shot at me by the way uh
because who do you think you
are i like it because you like to do the
flip you love to do the flip
sorry what's that yeah you do you like
no i cuz i don't like carrying wallets
so i'm going to transfer to this and
then uh that's insane to me
that you would put that's that that's
garbage that's less garbage than my mom
using a ziploc bag to put her credit
cards and [ __ ] bank cards and keys
and
cough drops in you put all your [ __ ] in
there you lose it
you're done yeah you call td bank tell
them to [ __ ] you they're i have the apps
you got responsibilities now it's not
just you you lose that thing i'm in
trouble
you're in trouble to begin with big guy
i don't i hate to break it to you
i just try to explain corporate
accounting to folium god damn
i was like it was like [ __ ]
waterboarding myself i don't get it
really get it counter argument i'm not
chemically addicted
to my wallet i'm way more likely just to
lose my wallet than i have my cell phone
that i'm checking every five years
six minutes true i don't think i've ever
lost a cell phone
he likes to watch his bands and go to
get to tickets for the shoes
and all that kind of stuff and then
touch base with the homies and the
homies
oh that's the homie
the uh while we're on the subject this
is a perfect segue into the first
question
guys so as you know when you sign up for
patreon we'll get we'll we'll answer
your garbage questions kind of the best
way to do it we also pull some from the
facebook but
uh when you join patreon we'll answer
your questions just the best way to to
go back to getting to everybody's
questions
um this is from steve isaacs did your
mom use her cleavage as a purse for a
cell phone bernie's lighter etc
that's a real dog to bounty hunter wife
[ __ ] well she used to pull out like a
[ __ ] stun gun and pepper spray out of
them things
you talking about the titty bank oh the
titty bank dude that's a [ __ ] game
i don't think i don't think you know i
don't i don't want to speak bad about it
i don't think denise yeah that's a
i don't know it was only she got a
handful it was only bigger broads that
would do that it was like big
boisterous blonde broads would do that
here's the only except girls that would
hit you with an uppercut
really packing their [ __ ] in there they
have a rolling stones tongue right yeah
yes yes yeah um
no she never did that you do it
pulls out a microphone get all the
t-shirt money in here you got all the
t-shirts in there
the only time that's acceptable is i
would say
from 1981 to 1995.
and i feel you got to be at like the
beach or a concert hundred percent no
con first of all my mom's not going to a
concert wait your mom was doing it on
the beach
i'm saying that's where you would do it
if you were at the pool
or you were at the because we went to a
community pool
quit bragging and if the ice cream man
showed up
yeah [ __ ] patty better make with the
[ __ ] ones
yeah with that kitty sweater if i gotta
chase this guy down the street
i'm gonna need an extra choco taco and a
screwball to get my head right
to get my [ __ ] my bearings i got my
legs back
under me i need a post workout [ __ ]
post workout
still got my sea legs strawberry
shortcake um
that would be the only time but no and
dude i've seen
[ __ ] waitresses do that oh not at
strip clubs yeah
pull change out of your [ __ ] wet pity
bad you smell it sure i mean the only
putting it in your shoe i had to do that
as a kid if you had like basketball
shorts or whatever you got to [ __ ]
put a put a fiver in there
marty funkhouser you gotta do what you
gotta do back in the day
pockets when you were a kid imagine not
having pockets now as an adult oh it's
crazy but like as a kid you're like i
don't know any pockets can you hold your
like what the [ __ ]
what are you doing with all your gear
dude where are the bernies at
we used to jock our [ __ ] we called it
whereas like if you had
um it would go like say you had
basketball shorts on
and boxers this is like pre-boxer brief
you had like like the puffy baggy boxers
they would be about so the shorts would
stop here then the boxers would stop
here
yeah you put like your sigs and lighter
in there if you didn't have
if you didn't have pockets what in
county like where the [ __ ] hell if you
were like
when you're out for the day yo stuff
that's in your ass the ceo's coming
and i never i wasn't smoking at 13 like
you i was a cool
[ __ ] kid what do you start smoking
until after
after all your college football days
we've all heard the stories high school
lower the lights lightest thing huh
foley's about to get into the varsity
years i was i would i i didn't have a
pack of cigarettes
on me when i was shooting hoops i mean
we were [ __ ] we were mature kids i
don't know what you want
instead of taking water breaks we were
ripping marshmallows and divorces
here comes here comes this [ __ ] to get
her alimony money
yeah that's that's garbage man i'm not
saying it's class
foley's eating ice cream kippy's down by
the docks finding dead bodies
oh [ __ ] here's another one
[ __ ] dewey le chance or whatever
whatever is that do we look chance
whatever corey feldman's name was and
stand by me
his name i know it was the chance i
don't know what his first name was
um the only thing that i could
slightly connect to that with is for a
little while
in the early 80s there was two
sneaker crates that swept over this is
pre jordan's
pre you know name brands i mean you
might have a nike or two
but you're old enough to have shoes
pre-name brand
i'll take the white ones well the
cobbler came around the farm about
every six months you can have any color
you want as long as it's black
model t no we had um uh
a company called wildcats which was the
big sneakers i remember wildcats
back when they went hot i mean i never
they were more of a tj maxx brand
yeah that's what i'm saying for for you
know for poor kids dude remember to
teach
get and shoot we had to do it a couple
of times like shoes at tj they were just
like in a bin
and you had to like dig through the bin
and they were like connected with that
plastic thing
it was a real tough one it was a dude it
was a real looking back on it now who
the [ __ ] cares
i know so there was some of those trips
with back to school stuff that i'd be
like damn
we're [ __ ] broke
like am i going to get lunch money
tomorrow yeah or am i about to put it on
my feet yeah save the kids
but no there was take the pizza bagel
tomorrow
i'll wear a flip-flop as long as i get
my otis spunks um
kangaroos uh which had a zipper on the
side of the pocket
he used to [ __ ] tuck it in the shoe
yeah you said tucked a couple of
quarters
a couple of bucks yeah because you came
across a pack of doritos that you had
had your name on it hit the vending
machine
yeah which was big which was after you
and i think we might have touched on at
one point was the muskets
the chad muska skate shoes with a stash
pocket in the top
the tongue because remember skate shoes
had like the big he
they had a big tongue and a zipper on
him who was his name chad muscat
that sounds like something a deer emits
when it
when it's running stop that's no muscus
but they had a zip and you could fit
like they claimed you could fit like an
eighth and a skate tool and a lighter in
there or something like all whatever you
needed
yeah and the commercial no it wasn't a
commercial it was very
like tongue-in-cheek no pun intended it
was very like you know hey this is for
extra bearings or whatever put your dope
is to put your [ __ ] hash in there
baby
ushiba your panama right your skateboard
non-public property
yeah yeah yeah that was big i remember
my boy pat he still denies this but he
came up to me and he's like
he had just gotten the muscus and he
came up to me in like eighth grade
hallways like dude i'm packing i'm like
get out of my face
you [ __ ] door you want some bubble
tape
i got jolly ranchers in here loving
jolly ranch
oh excellent [ __ ] question man this
next one
is it really out of the feeling the
smell
everything got to me and i've never
thought of this this is from uh
i hope i'm pronouncing it piravine um
pyruvine
uh at a public pool or water park have
you ever laid on the concrete to warm up
oh yeah dude i can feel that now
like a salamander in the serengeti are
you kidding me
the gilly bacon dude the kids do that
now it's so funny you mentioned that but
like
my nephew my niece and like you can't do
it as an adult let's say that
you can't be [ __ ] 32 laying down next
to the pool
laying down on a tennis court
really soaking it in um they'll go out
to the driveway
and bring their towels to to get to dry
yeah and don't dude there's nothing
because i'm i'm very attached to smell
like like you know nostalgic purposes
i would have never thought but i used to
love
like you know like i would like get down
in the street and smell like the fresh
asphalt
asphalt after it rains in the summer
that smell when it's still
hot but kind of cool oh baby little
slice of america
that's an apple pie and wet coffee
that's what
i'm singing about right there i'll tell
you that right now good
night that little fresh cut grass mixed
in maybe a [ __ ] couple a
couple of burgers on the grill good
night and goodbye
you got some sparklers coming after
dinner too i love it but i know
the combination of chlorine water and um
and cement like you know on sidewalk
nothing like
it it's clean living babies that's dude
i knew i hadn't talked about that i took
a trip over by the [ __ ] jet in the in
the pool put your little stinger by
there
yeah that's that was that was the the
kid's version of having a smoke after
you [ __ ] up
after you pulled it in the pool
[Music]
i'm gonna get to second base with the
jets then go lay in the driveway
i'll be back in about an hour
i'm gonna run out
get something to eat afterwards i'm
drained
foley really likes the shallow end of
the pool
i thought when i did that as a kid i
thought i was on to something
yeah i thought you thought no one knew
what you were doing you guys were all
idiots
you guys are down on the diving board
the action's in the shallow
[Laughter]
hey i should be charging this
there should be 25 of these hey you guys
can be diving for rings all you want
i'm over here get my knob slobbed
by mr thirsty
[Laughter]
what's the matter t you didn't do it
yours couldn't fit probably
this guy had to find a manhole
he had to go to the heights in the
summer toby get out of that storm drain
it's clogged up no honestly what i was
thinking about when katie said dive in
for rings
there is no scrape like the scrape of a
bottom of a pool in the face
there's something in that concrete but
it's this it's the
face i've done it do it hitting it it's
this weird sensation it's a weird
feeling
yeah yeah for sure yeah makes a weird
noise under the water
ooh summer's right around the corner i
can't wait ah man it's gonna be a good
summer kids got a couple of bucks in
their pockets going on a road
it's gonna be a hot one no more day jobs
for gippy flipping slides for everybody
yeah take that accounting department
kippy's free this summer goodbye
hey gang real quick want to talk to you
about one of our favorite new sponsors
here on the show
lucy nicotine oh yeah lucy nicotine is a
company
founded by cal tech scientists and
former smokers
looking for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative couple of brainiacs
on the case
a couple of smart kids working the ones
and twos i'll tell you that gang
and finally we have a brand new tobacco
alternative that doesn't
suck yeah because we know they all stink
these guys researched and developed
for the last three years and made this
product
for people not patients they know you're
a human being
and they want to get it to you and they
want to get it to your right lucy has
created nicotine gum
with four milligrams of nicotine that
comes in three
amazing flavors you got wintergreen you
got cinnamon
and if you like it a little bit on the
fruity side yeah which i know i do
yep try pomegranate class it up a little
bit and that ain't it baby they also
have a lozenge and four milligrams of
nicotine
in the cherry ice flavor baby that's
what i'm talking about
cherry ice and everything nice each and
every flavor actually tastes great it's
convenient and it's discreet products
can be enjoyed anywhere on flights at
work
office to go wherever you are you can do
it nobody's gotta know
don't gotta step outside like uh even
the gym baby whatever you're doing you
could be on a stair master doing this
nobody's gotta know you're getting you
know you're uh you're getting a little
nicotine
yeah um they sent us some and we
absolutely love it delicious we're all
hooked on the bernies everybody knows
we're trying to get off
it's it's a way better substitute than
most people than anything i've ever
really had 100
i was never a big fan of the gum i've
done it in the past this stuff is
different they're playing with it
they're playing with house money over
here they do it right
yeah so guys check it out it's 20 21 get
rid of your cigarettes unplug your vape
throw out your dip
and get some lucy nicotine gum or
lozenges it's the way to go
it's the real deal baby a subscription
to lucy
comes directly to your door each month
it's so simple and easy you don't have
to be at your house
delivery is everything all comes
automatic you know automatic you don't
have to do nothing
are you garbage listeners go to lucy.co
and use promo code garbage to get 20
off all the products on your first order
including gum and lozenges
that's lucy.co and use promo code
garbage at the checkout
also i have to give this disclaimer a
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical guys
that's lucy dacio and be sure to use
that promo code garbage
[ __ ] fantastic well those those are
why we do this show something like that
to take me back
that's the juice right there um this is
from gary ever left the restaurant
because there was no prices on the menu
[Laughter]
i can't say i've ever even no
no i've been probably a handful i've not
gone because when i looked at the
website there was no prices i've never
not done that i've i've never not done
that
i've never know knowingly gone in and
the whole menu be [ __ ]
oh of course not you wouldn't go i
wouldn't go
something really [ __ ] up has to happen
for the foleys to have the
um the non-social anxiety
to get up and leave i would never leave
i would i would just go like oh i'm not
gonna pay rent i'm gonna pay rent late
or whatever
i'll get the appetizer and a drink and
make it look like i'm supposed to be
here
let me go out on a corner and get a
[ __ ] dog or something yeah my dad
would never
he could he i'd be too embarrassed to
leave yeah for social media for any
reason if like you're waiting for a long
time for service
it would take a good 45 minutes before
my parents got up and left i would think
yeah yeah they would be too embarrassed
to leave because there's something
i don't know why there's something weird
about it it's happened to me on a date
before
what showed up to a place it looks plays
a nice date with a girl
no price on the menu how did you get
into a place like that but the way you
carry yourself the haircut the clothes
what were you wearing that they let you
in
uh they must have been like he must be
early bitcoin adopter or something
i i walked in i said i developed apps
i'll have you here yeah something you
went under the guide they must have been
like oh someone's here and then when you
tipped them 15 cents
it's still launching um that's bad but
did you roll out
no i just i just spit the bullet just
just just outside just like
oh this place is great inside sweat sure
i mean it's
it's a real [ __ ] douchebag thing to
do
and you know i mean the restaurant
business has changed so much that i
don't think too many people are doing it
now
you've got to have a lot of balls it'd
be pretty good to be pulling that [ __ ]
off
what there's not many restaurants that
do that now sure there's also too
my wife's very like she'll look at i'm
just so
blue collared trap like we don't we
don't have refined pallets or anything
you know what i mean like
that if something is market price on a
menu or doesn't have a pr like
i'm saying you go to a regular
restaurant everything's lined up but
there's like three or four things that
are market prices
down at the [ __ ] bottom of the minute
yeah the owner's box yeah the [ __ ]
vip
club level baby did the ryan's don't
whipped
no way but we've i've worked in enough
restaurants to know that
those last couple of things there's only
a few things that are acceptable for it
to be
sure lobster it can't be the mac and
cheese or something yeah yeah
sometimes sometimes what did macaroni
close out today yeah that's a gold medal
that's
[Laughter]
wait that's like my scallop bit goldman
um yeah it's got to be it's got to be
you know there's got to be the stamp
sure
it's usually it's usually like you know
uh the surf and turf or the lobster or
whatever
but my wife really she's got no problem
[ __ ] sniffing around the owner's box
yeah she goes right anna what says what
i think that and i'm just like
you don't even that's how they get you
you don't look at that that's
interesting you bring that up because i
i was thinking about that
just um this thursday night
um we got back uh into town on thursday
i'm familiar i was i was doing some work
uh friday and saturday
near where my parents live sure so i
drove down
um friday yeah and then friday night
we went out to have dinner together you
wanna fam me and the fam
yeah you picking this up i picked it up
what was the bill
it was really important to me to take i
understand one of the things my family
had to do
i have the same i have the same feeling
what was the bill if you don't mind me
asking uh it was only like uh
250 or something like that only 250. it
wasn't big on this guy
250. listen you ain't never don't say
it's only 250 to me
okay it's say it was 250 i'm really
proud of it do not say only
i don't want people out there think i'm
spending i wouldn't like drop
500 or anything well only 250 makes it
sound like you do
drop 250 a lot really it was only 250.
250 is a lot
for a din din yeah
toby custom champagne some more bread
for the bulls too
i i meant it wasn't that bad i know you
mean either way that being here nor
there
um you said your wife pulls the trigger
your wife pulls heavy on the trigger
this is the first time i've taken my
parents out to dinner
i think ever yeah i've never taken my
parents out today yeah so
i'll buy her a drink if we're out at the
we're at the pub or something i'll buy
you around we're going
we're going around for round but you
know let her win her
yeah all right she but she gets when i
get one but it was important for me to
order the shots on her
obviously they didn't want me to and
they're like my dad's like what are you
doing you know what i mean like
it means a lot for you yes i went down
the shore with uh for like easter and we
went out i'm like i'm getting the booze
i'm getting the p like
it was like the night before
thanksgiving not thanksgiving you're
handing out solo cups
well no it was like we were going to
liquor store for the weekend and i'm
like i got it i got like let me i'm like
i've been riding the [ __ ] hotel
34 years like kippy spent a little bit
of cage but i was thinking
about um you know because obviously
there was an announcement made
before the meal get whatever you want
uncle hank's uncle hank's team sure and
you were probably
very overbearing throughout the meal
about that
ridiculous cause that's just that's
that's you're overbearing
i love you you're overbearing to begin
with but then when you are
taking care of something you're very now
get the extra
get two of them hey dad don't forget the
bread i ordered all the appetizers
all of them in the country i'll take
them all i said is anything anybody
specifically wants
let's get some muscles started let's get
started which is very i'm not taking
away he's very nice of you yeah very
very
some of these some of these some of
these some of that so i you know i see
we get whatever you want
now i was thinking okay because you just
said your wife
like say your wife goes out to dinner
with your family yeah all right let's
say she orders second or third
does she match the price or does she
just order whatever the [ __ ] she feels
like
because i think that's what you were
getting at you said she'll pull the
trigger
no i'm saying with me and her um
because i was i we're not go she'll get
yeah i don't and i'm just using her not
herself yeah no i'm trying to think i
don't know i've never
so here's my question i don't know the
parents got a little bit of gas they're
throwing around sure here's my question
is it garbage that you threw 250 around
into karaba's yes
how many big macs was that
250 and big macs ain't that much yeah to
be honest with choice if you're getting
a super sized meal they get you
they don't screw around mcdonald's ain't
cheap um
is it garbage to like to to over to
you order the most expensive thing on
the menu if you're not paying for it
i think it's tacky yes right it depends
it also depends on who you're with so
that's what you know what i did
what i ordered the most expensive thing
on the menu so everybody felt
comfortable
do you
i got the blooming onion
i'll take two orders of mozzarella
sticks as an entree
can you put them on one plate please and
is that trash i'm sure you've done that
because you're a weird little factor
ordering appetizers as your entree yeah
what am i a [ __ ]
circle of course the chicken is going to
potato skins
oh yeah i no
crush a [ __ ] pee skin right now dog
crush a pea skin shout out to friday's
doing it
all right friday saturday's inside i'll
tell you that
i got a question for both you guys have
you ever gotten the specials
that were not on the menu that were read
to you by the waiter this was of course
you [ __ ] yes
never this was the thing the ryan's
black out that cause there's something
going on
don't even read them to me i've never
listened to a [ __ ]
special [ __ ] table i've never
listened to a special i go yeah zip zip
it's not david if it ain't on a menu
if it ain't on the menu i don't know why
isn't it on the menu my man because
that's not the way it works because it's
special they have special ingredients
that came in that day
they got it fresh well if it's so good
it would be in the prime times
yeah i'm not saying it ain't good t-bone
you're f you're trash yeah that's trash
both of you come on welcome to the show
baby i'm not saying like a [ __ ]
rockefeller
you get the special i might have done it
once or twice if i hear it on the
[ __ ] rip right away if i go oh that's
it
i'm done i'm pulling a trigger on that
i've done it once or twice in a really
nice place
they don't tell you that number's on
those though that's how they get you
yeah
yeah uh it's not a it's not a money
thing i just think we were
i grew up in a household where i'm like
we're not that's for fancy people
that's for that ain't us give me the
[ __ ]
goulash in the you know give me the soup
and just soup in a salad or whatever
that ain't us i always listen to the
specials i make eye contact i do
oh okay oh you know the crab that sounds
not bad
if i'm interested in something i ask how
much it is that usually pisses off my
girlfriend cause that's trash
you can't be asking how much the special
is no
what do you mean if they don't tell you
have a little tape have a little pack
uh how much are the soft shells oh 45 oh
okay we'll keep
okay i'll take the chicken fingers
two lemons in a diet coke we'll need a
couple more minutos here my friend
yeah um so that i was curious about that
i was very nice to cooking i would never
over
i would never step over but it's also
like if someone but i wanted to set that
tone
i wanted to make sure that everything's
gonna come feel free yeah plus i want it
to fillet
my [ __ ] jerk off yeah on the [ __ ]
strip like an [ __ ] it is nice
to uh to finally not have to worry about
like this bill is going to be 70
of my net worth and that was it that was
a celebratory dinner now it's back to
business back to work relax
jesus christ back out here for you folks
dude you're allowed to have a dinner
with your family relax
am i now we know why we spent 20 minutes
before the show fully going away so like
how does the money from
live shows break down because i had a
bit of a bill on my hands
meanwhile you're sniffing around the
[ __ ] you're sniffing around the
corporate bank account
all because you [ __ ] blew it on
oysters or whatever
hey you were hitting me up for money
like i owed you money
like dude the way you were asking
questions i blew my twitty sniping for
the money
dude the way you were like i'm back to
zero now just everybody
the way you were grilling me on expenses
and income
it was like i was like dude am i doing
something wrong i'm like looking at toby
i'm like what's going on hang on you
know it's a little dicey too i don't
like
um treadmills
i don't trust them when you use your
card to [ __ ]
to pay the bill the tip doesn't go on it
immediately
oh they get you coming and going on that
i got about you get whacked on tuesday
for that one i got 25 percent of 250 out
there [ __ ]
waiting to [ __ ] linger bang me over
there
like a sock full of nickels [ __ ]
catch you while you're sleeping i'm
sweating out of the process that
overnight uber does that too don't think
i'm not up there
is that gonna drop yeah they get it just
put it on there right now i want to get
it all in front of me
you know let me know what i'm [ __ ]
working with i got [ __ ] four ipas of
me you think i'm gonna remember 22
not happening yeah i gotta [ __ ] check
my six on thursday
come on dude check your six was a big
line of the [ __ ]
the first leg of the door too we were
saying that's all yo check your [ __ ]
six
yikes yeah i've made a lot of hairy
game time decisions with a couple
pending transactions
oh man that's what i love about navy
federal the second that you use it
army d the second that you use it they
keep it they keep they keep it right in
front of you man
keep it right in front of you it's great
fully what do you got in your bank
account
cannonballs and spices a couple of
anchors
few shillings
are you going to make a deposit today
guy who had the fellaini is the banker
the waiter too
um i haven't flushed it out yet all
right this one's for me and
have you i was gonna charge him for an
overdraft fee but he invoked the right
to party
[Laughter]
no quarter this month on the interest
rates we could do this
all day come on we used to do this on
center city comedy back in the day when
you first got the navy federal account
that's watch out for our new podcast
aria pirates
thought that was going to hit really
hard i mean we just said we've been
doing the same joke for 45 seconds fair
enough
um all right this is from ian have you
ever asked an uber driver if it's okay
to smoke
that's the in finance i would assume no
it's not no no no no
um why i used to do it with taxis was
big religiously
especially cool if i smoke in here
why get in they light one up with you
they bum one give it a lighter
back in the day with a couple of [ __ ]
roots keys in here early 2000 like you
know probably 2006
to probably i don't even know philly was
still kind of lawless nothing better
than smoking in the cab on a friday
night when you got a couple of things in
here
yeah yeah oh i was when you got a couple
a couple of
a couple of things rattling around in
new york you couldn't do it with an uber
it's two it's not their car it's too
regulated but i've taken uber's on the
road in like michigan and [ __ ]
yeah that's where that guy goes you care
if i smoke i go buddy
have at it that's the real question i've
never had a cab driver ask if it's okay
if you smoke yeah garbage i've had that
for sure
trash yeah yeah yeah but no uh [ __ ] i
remember [ __ ]
crushing whippets in the back of a
[ __ ] cab doing [ __ ] 55 up the
[ __ ] fdr back in the day are you
that's cut that yeah i mean jesus christ
[ __ ] guy playing it fast and loose um
all right uh this one's from eddie davis
first time question has anyone in your
family
or you washed and then dried and reused
a paper towel or napkin
i'm sorry what has anyone in your family
or you
washed then dried and reused a paper
towel or napkin
no that's disgusting
i okay but you can what what
so when i wash and dry my hands
uh-huh i'm not intentional wait why are
you drying your hands with a paper towel
don't you have a [ __ ] hand towel in
the bathtub yeah but sometimes no like
if i'm in the
if i wash my hands in the kitchen if i
come in from outside
okay or like if i'm cooking or something
okay and like i'm like oh i got
something i gotta rinse and i'll do that
okay and i'll sometimes keep it around
oh yeah that's okay
and then reuse it but you're not [ __ ]
like hanging it to dry like a towel i'm
not doing a load of [ __ ]
load of bounties downstairs in the
basement like a [ __ ] jerk-off
i got a load of paper towels and wait a
minute
that's a real delicate cycle yeah you
got to do that on cold
nah that's trash i've never seen that
but every one of my
everyone i know has has about 900
chipotle napkins
sure a drawer or something oh sure i'm a
big listen
keep your napkins gang you're [ __ ]
you're doing good for the environment
sometimes you get handed up you need
them
keep them i can't do it anytime i get
napkins i throw a [ __ ] stack in the
glove in the glove box
yeah so if i [ __ ] sneeze on the
turnpike and i got bugs all over my face
or on my hands
i don't want to put that on the wheel i
[ __ ] lean over it
pull it out clean up sure we talked
about this i think it's
trashy a little bit to keep a roll of
paper towels in the car that's
ridiculous
it's great we're great it's great but
limo drivers do that
i know but you're no limo driver it just
seems a little
i don't know i keep that i keep uh uh
armor all glass cleaner and i keep uh
tuba armor all wipes in my car all times
all times i guess i was in there it was
a little hurt and you could use uh you
could use a
s i'm getting squeezed i'm getting your
detailed on monday i'm getting it
what are you gonna do when you okay well
tell me when you return that thing
you're smoking bernie's in there
uh no i wasn't yeah i know that's what
you asked me you said no well bring it
up so i brought it up
no i wasn't if you work at conicelli
down there conicelli nissan and jp
kennedy
nissan and chrysler um that's the
details
okay you get that out i'm not smoking in
mine no
no okay folks let's
take the overrun what what
truthfully honest with you when i do if
i do i will 100
let's put it how many days or when a
date
you're smoking in that car by the end of
the summer no way no doubt about it no
way
dude is that the date is that the over
under we want to poke what are you going
to be the irishman and [ __ ] pull over
to have a cigarette that's it so labor
day is what we're saying before
september august 30th
driving back and forth to the shore
you're lying now you've smoked enough
i for sure haven't one million percent i
haven't
i'm telling you it's a new day labor day
well it was september first he's saying
two grand oh you put money on it two
grand
no you pay us two grand if you don't
what do i do if i do it what do i get if
i do it
good on you yeah no get the [ __ ] out of
here
[ __ ] bozo bet um all right this is uh
resist the great reset uh
have you ever used anything other than a
belt to support your pants
i believe i have yeah yeah shoelace
a lot one shoelace will get around you
though three shoelaces
three sets of shoes big big skater thing
back in the day yeah so you don't have
the belt buckle yeah slapping around
lightweight
i uh i'm sure i've done something in a
jam i think i use it
uh especially when we used to like work
construction and stuff and call it it
would be like
if your belt broke or whatever you had
to do like an extension cord or
something or like wire or whatever
if your pants are falling down you're
doing manual labor
guys are grabbing at you so bad
uh no well like your pants would be
falling down and yeah you'd have to do
something
i for sure remember doing something on
like on the [ __ ] on job sites but
um never like to a [ __ ] never to
school or something
i used to wear my football belt all the
time you know the little of course you
do they're like
nylon yeah yeah without the two little
hooks yeah those are great
you remember and i'd go in and then you
fold it over and it hangs down a little
bit a little bit that was big do you
remember
these were like these were big back in
the day a pair of [ __ ] nice
timberlands with your jeans cuffed
and your [ __ ] football jersey on on a
friday before a game
[ __ ] i thought you were [ __ ]
johnny cool guy
joe high school over here until you got
smacked around on the field
yeah [ __ ] you're [ __ ] out you
don't know where you are the
cheerleaders are [ __ ] rolling their
eyes
you're lining up next to them
[Laughter]
blue 42 they're going go team go there
what the [ __ ]
foley's out to lunch again go buffalos
uh what was big back in the day i
remember one summer or whatever it was
like a fab but they were like
hand woven colored kind of like
native american or south american like
uh woven belts braided belts not braided
i know exactly where you are braided
were
braided were dope too and you would flip
them down through the [ __ ] thing they
would have been a braided belt your ass
gonna get beat up they were big
especially in like the skater world the
braided belt was big and then
there was the other one uh i think they
called them like military belts they had
like the
they were there oh my god
my dad used to wear them all the time
for his navy uniform i love those things
cute
cats for team uniform i love those
slide it in and you slide slide the
thing down yeah they were big
when we were they were big when you were
a little kid and they were big when you
junior high they hit and there was this
place mr rags opened up in the oxford
valley mall was like this
wannabe pacific sun wear type thing i
don't know
i don't know if it was a national chain
or whatever but mr rags and they had
like
the ufo pants and like you know the cool
[ __ ]
the cool [ __ ] that you wanted as a
[ __ ] 13 or 12 year old or whatever it
was
and they had you got to pick your own
buckle and then they would they had just
wheels of that and like
nylon or whatever it is yeah because it
had teeth on the thing
well the teeth yes when that thing went
bad though you were done you were done
yeah so you would make your own in any
color you want dude and that hit we all
there's
like a bunch of [ __ ] dorks that's
pretty
17 dudes all went into mr rags and all
bought the same [ __ ]
military belt or whatever they're
getting yeah that's pretty good man you
felt like a [ __ ]
king rocking that thing that ain't too
[ __ ] shabby right there those things
were [ __ ] awesome
yeah uh i was a suspenders guy for a
minute
no belt but suspenders yeah for like a
half a minute suspenders were cool i
remember wearing suspenders to high
school at one point with jeans
man rough weeks cigs in your [ __ ]
sleeve
who does that what was that what fad was
that based on it was like you know i was
like the swing
or something the swing like remember the
swing got cool no i wasn't a rockabilly
it was like
well you just told me you were [ __ ]
dude you just told me you were a fighter
michael j
fox more than [ __ ] back to the future
is that what you were basing it i'm
asking you yeah what do you mean man he
was pretty [ __ ] cool
i'm not i'm not saying he wasn't i'm
saying what was it based on it was based
on that michael j
fox and ferris bueller that's why i keep
i don't know if it's garbage but i keep
all my stuff when i get in my car
i take everything out of my pockets oh
my [ __ ] i put her all on the passengers
you lose it
all the time well you know why i do that
you always say get up is there a lighter
under you is there a hoagie under you
because that's what marty mcfly did in
the delorean he put everything next to
him i love that
crank the power of love or no marty
mcfly more like a marty mcdonald's am i
right
all right uh dude on stage in
raleigh i made it some really hacky
cheap [ __ ] fat joke and everybody's
like oh i'm like this is what you pay
for
this is what keeps it going maybe uh
sorry i'm sniffing
allergies uh yeah i have a sip of water
your throat's a little drier yeah i'm
sorry mine too i'm hurting
the burnings ain't hoping either um all
right this is from
uh brandon hundley it just says five
second rule question mark
ouch i don't know are you you do play by
the five-second rule
sig's on the street no yes what
i drop a sig i'm picking it up pam that
new york pandemic you're picking a cig
up off the
sidewalk one single [ __ ] person from
[ __ ] beijing the [ __ ] delaware has
gotten [ __ ]
coronavirus from [ __ ] you don't know
that
off the street you don't know that i got
people in the w.h.o
i talked to the who w.h.o come on
[Laughter]
kippy's too quick over here gunslinger i
talked to baba o'reilly
uh now i'm weird with food
it's got to be in my house i'll do it if
something drops it can't be
wet but my thing is it can't be wet wet
on a carpet
is a no-no because that comes up all
fuzzy you got dog hair you don't even
have a dog what the [ __ ]
yeah it comes up at five o'clock shadow
i ain't doing that oh
no in the kitchen if i drop like a
pretzel nugget or something i'll go for
it oh yeah
yeah yeah you also do the real [ __ ]
dirty
it's dirty and it's super trashy if you
bump
i don't pack my sig so when i give foley
a sig out of my pack
he takes it and then just bangs it on
whatever
salt like it could be a door it could be
someone else's car it could be a [ __ ]
it's fire hydrant bananas it's so gross
dude you know what else i do
also it's crazy that you don't pack your
sex i'm old school baby you know what
else
uh i think i'm starting to realize it's
trashy that i do
i don't know if anybody else does it but
if i'm eating in a restaurant
and something falls off my plate i'll
take it off the table and eat it yeah
it's trashy
is it it depends how quick and what it
is and what the table is but yeah
probably
yeah like i mean it could be it could be
like a little piece of macaroni salad
i'm picking that up and i'm eating it
on a tablecloth or just a table or are
you eating it as a tablecloth i go to
nice places you do
yeah no right i'm not eating anything
off a wooden
i'm not eating anything off the table
yeah i'll eat it i'll do it
no i'll do it nope not for kipping i'll
do it i'll do it right now
not for kippy um all right this next
one's from brian have you ever
one second sure sorry to completely
derail it uh you said macaroni salad
macaroni salad versus potato salad who
wins i don't [ __ ] with either one of
them
yeah i'm nuts i'm getting both next
question
i don't think yeah i'm not i'm not
splitting those up
causing trouble between those two you
crazy
yeah don't start a civil war in the
foley house i want the [ __ ] peculiar
platter with the [ __ ]
egg salad mac salad coleslaw i love all
that [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] all that i'll eat waldorf
salad until my [ __ ] face falls up
chicken walnuts and [ __ ] uh
grapes dumbledorf a little bit of celery
love all those prepared salads yeah
great
um macaroni salad brain spray
uh yeah i thought it doesn't do i don't
like cold stuff really
you're weird just has a blanket
yeah i don't like a lot of am i i like i
like heating up your peanut butter
i like my stuff i gotta like everybody
knows that just
peanuts look you haven't lived to you
had hot ice
cream did you ever have a deep fried no
yeah i know you buddy we talked about it
i know i
even if we didn't talk about it i could
have changed i i i would have put pretty
good money on these
cheese in there fried ice cream a lot of
korean places do it too
they have fried ice cream um it's great
awesome um yeah i just don't do colds
i don't do cold stuff that's supposed to
be warm that makes sense potatoes are
supposed to be warm
you draw something airlines in the same
man i know dude
i know i know i know i don't know why
either i'm sure i
i i'm sure i would love it i just should
be hanging out with 11 in the gang this
kid's cuckoos
i get a nosebleed
every time i throw out a softball that i
think's going to be a little panda back
and forth
i like this like this it comes like i
don't [ __ ] do that yeah do that
around me
you're gonna get stared sure no hey have
all the max salad you want it's just
iced tea or lemonade only if it's hot
no well i'm not a [ __ ] jerk off i
like a nice cold beverage everybody
knows that
um also shout out to i think his name
was jp he was she was drinking in the
[ __ ] parking lot
of zany's before brought an ipa ran up
they ran
ran up to me and gave me an ipa he goes
oh here you go [ __ ] so sweet yeah it
was great thank you how about a shout
out to the kid in the airport
oh [ __ ] yeah i can't i see you in boston
yeah
see you in boston buddy i got shot by
the can and said hello to uncle hey
yeah kid kid [ __ ] ran up behind me
like hey man big fan took a pic
everything looked at toby goes oh so
you're the other guy i'll get it
uh but you're not skinnier in person
than i thought airport recognized is
pretty [ __ ] cool
nice i was a [ __ ] that was a weak
changer for me weak
changer that was in the giants i was
like where the [ __ ] were you last night
we could have used you to [ __ ] juice
the numbers a little bit
keep the guys on the coast yeah um
all right where was i all right this is
from brian uh have you ever used the
water bottle holder on your bicycle as a
beer holder
why am i drinking on a bike every
vacation i've ever been on i've drank on
a bike
really every time i go down to the shore
we get we got the beach cruises with the
cup holder
a couple of pops in there i don't do
bikes
i'm more of a golf cart we got the golf
cart too
i think every beer i've ever consumed on
a bike was shotgunned
shotgun and on on the bike while you're
riding yeah
what kind of bike did you have in
chicago i bet it was really annoying
probably a lot of tape on it fixie or
something not a fixie single speed
single speed no fixie was it that was it
a 10 speed that had the
the the the horns that go down no no no
drop handles it wasn't 10 speed was a
single speed it had the like just
regular t-bar handles
bar for a t-bone wait single speed was
it a mountain bike or a bmx bike
uh it's a road bike what does that mean
i'm out i don't know either does it look
like a mountain bike
no i think what you call a mountain bike
yes it's not a bmx bike
no yeah so it's a mountain bike to him
it's a mountain bike to me as well
it's a mountain bike either way if you
pulled up with that i go look at the
dork on the mountain
that's what i would say either way get
out of traffic take that [ __ ] on the
sidewalk i'm late for a while hey buddy
hit the park
uh yeah it was a big we do it uh
when i would go over and visit my wife
too because you're allowed to just drink
in
public over there so we'd like ride to
the water get some beers on the ride a
couple of
you know open it up hop in a couple of
pops
yes it's trash i mean come on i think
it's good clean fun
no it's trash i mean it's trashy if
you're like you got like a [ __ ]
riding bikes is trash that's nuts i mean
that's the most insane statement riding
bikes is trash yeah man come what are
you doing adults riding bikes
get out of here with that it's a good
time it's exercise gets the blood
pumping
you don't have to look for parking i'm
not saying in new york you're riding a
bike in new york you're a [ __ ] goob
but you're down to shore in wildwood
come on
cruising down surf you've got the wind
at your hair you're going down to the
beach
all right we're gonna get some clam
strips you got a boogie board under your
arm an ipa
hanging out all right i could see that
good time you got the beach cruiser with
the big handles you're stopping at a
crab cake got a little basket got your
moons bumping on your phone
all right come on i like it
not bad not too shitty we gotta stop
somewhere for lunch
yeah of course that's where we're going
oh that's not bad yeah come on ride a
bike to lunch and [ __ ] lock it up out
front can you get can you get arrested
for riding a bike drunk
uh toby drunk you can yeah uh
i mean i've ridden a bike sh
uh never ran into an issue yeah no they
can i got pulled over on a skateboard
one time on ellison avenue
for [ __ ] shredding too goddamn hard
and this is why
trucks are smoking this is what led me
to my like just shotgun to get it over
with
if you're out in public was i was
skating finishing tall boy pbr shout out
to kip
big fan of the tall boy pbr big fan
uh i've been living in chicago for about
five years at the time cop pulled me
over and was like yo you can't be
drinking into the street i just like
kicked my skateboard up it's just like
oh i didn't know i couldn't do that i'm
from florida pretty good excuse me and
the cop was like all right
have a good one sir um
we got a few more here uh this is from
ryan uh have you ever been kicked off
the go-karts for crashing into people
yeah that was big back in the day
trading paint the little rubbing rubbing
is racing baby we were really bad
yeah get out i couldn't do it if my
parents were there
like at that age because i'd get [ __ ]
dreamed for acting a [ __ ]
fraction of fool in public yeah but
would mean the boys went up by ourselves
differently yeah it was [ __ ] lawless
yeah i was doing like thunder road it
was tokyo drift out that [ __ ]
you know it's real embarrassing i
remember the first couple of times i
rode go-karts
or i couldn't for bumper cars i couldn't
figure it out you ever have the dirt
ball have to get up
and stand on the side [ __ ] steer
yeah you're crying like i can't do
it yeah it was always a big thing too
when you were in the bumper cars you got
moved up from you and your parent to
just you driving by yourself
i was like getting your learner's permit
that was that was a real tough look and
really defines
your your self-esteem is when if you and
your father
are in a go-kart together or in a bumper
car together and you're getting owned
oh yeah your dad can't get a hold of ah
goddammit just give me a minute here
i think i got a bad wheel that's a tough
look also by somebody like
by like a 13 year old or something who's
just [ __ ] him and his good time
buddies or [ __ ] got you cornered and
you're making fun of your dad you're
[ __ ] hemmed up back
they got to come break it up tough luck
they got a thing in chicago called
whirlyball
of course they do it's like you shotgun
a [ __ ] and handle a
soco and then you jerk off no it's
it's a combination of bumper cars
lacrosse and basketball
you basically have like who does that i
hope when we get to chicago
all the things you talk about everybody
says yeah nobody does that
that guy's [ __ ] lame yeah they're
like they're gonna be like if we pull
into the airport and everybody goes oh
[ __ ] toby's backpack
it sounds a lot i was going to give you
the [ __ ] it's like okay
it's not great sure but as like a
concert you could have stopped the
whirly ball
we didn't want to hear it we're going to
shoot that when we go to chicago fully
playing whirlybird
that's what i was thinking is it would
be good for a video i mean shoot me
getting a hot dog because that's the
only thing i'm doing
chai town i'm coming uh heavy
all right let's do a couple of moe
couple of mo here
uh this is a big one that i'm also we
should have done this earlier on we were
talking about this kind of stuff this is
from caleb
have you ever put your license or debit
card spending cash
in this the cellophane of a pack of
bernies as a makeshift wallet
that was also that's a big beach move or
like
we were going tubing or fishing or
whatever if you don't have pot if you're
wearing basketball shorts you take your
20
you slide it in the cellophane your
[ __ ] debit card or license in there
whatever you need
and then the lighter goes in the pack
which is trash backpack is garbage trash
[ __ ] garbage but i've done it oh i
also put other nefarious items inside a
pack of cigarettes
while there were cigarettes in there
then you got to go fishing around for
when you get to the bathroom
yeah yeah yeah that's a trash move very
but also at the same time you're going
to the beach that's what you do i mean
you condense everything down to one
[ __ ] thing otherwise you're losing
your [ __ ] you know
it's also it could be classy because
you're prepared i got my license i got
my debit card and i also got my bernie's
there we go i'm a big hide everything at
the beach right in my shoes
that's an old seinfeld bit is it yeah
yeah when you put it
they're not gonna find it if we put it
to the front of the shoe that's pretty
good yeah
yeah i hide everything um
all right this one's this isn't the same
thing this is from nick deluca shout out
to nikki bones
uh have you ever asked for a specific
color lighter out of bodega
all the time get the [ __ ] out of here no
it's what yeah
get out of here trashy sometimes i feel
like pink sometimes i want blacks yeah
but it shouldn't matter that's what i'm
saying you just go give me it's a
functional thing give me a lighter the
fact that having an
opinion and like attachment to it is why
it's trash wait i have a great question
what
what color lighter is bad luck where
you're from because it's white
yeah white white everywhere it's not
everywhere i've heard yellow in some
other places but
my buddy we picked up my buddy ryan uh
to go to like something
where are the ball sticks yeah we're the
ball stinks you want to co signing your
whirly ball
uh picked up my buddy ryan a couple
other like two or three other people to
go to [ __ ]
six flags one day we're in like high
school or something i got the i got the
96 chevy illumina paint chipping off
real good look got the head unit
installed with electrical tape
no big deal okay probably got some 50
cent or g unit bumping we're doing it
gibby's got a white tee a fitted hat on
backwards we're hanging we get it you're
a dork
that was cool let me talk about the
glory days would you have your eyes when
i was a third string tight end or
whatever
did you have your eyebrows on i had my
eyebrows on yeah um
so we're getting a picture but my buddy
gets in with a white lighter it was like
very light gray and i'm like dude he
like oh my god let me get a light and he
hands it to me i'm like
dude we're going on this trip like this
isn't fun what do you do get this thing
the [ __ ] out of you guys how you
believing that
god dude we like flat tire ran out of
gas we finally make it there we get in
we give them the tickets we wait in line
for like three hours to get to the front
of
you know johnny got murdered johnny [ __ ]
[ __ ] roller like batman or whatever the
big roller coaster is dude we are the
next in line
and electrical storm it gets stuck
upside down we have to turn around leave
the park the second we leave the park
no re-admittance the sun it's pouring
rain that we get outside and get to the
car the sun comes out
[ __ ] park opens back up we got we
waited it was like a seven-hour trip we
didn't do anything
blame that [ __ ] lighter ever since
i'll say anything but white is when i'm
ordering
when i'm getting a lighter about now
anything but white i like to pick
it's cause you're trash you know it's
really trashy the pack of matches in the
pack of bernies
that's that's kippy's [ __ ]
i'm a big i love light and bernie's all
these things smell like sulfur that's no
good
love lightness the first drag of a
[ __ ] bernie
off a book of matches is to die for
what's your book of matches technique
are you a flip over keep attached or are
you a pull off
and then flip the case the flipping the
cases
the flipping of the case is trash you
you take it off rip it out
close it strike the back do this
like this hit it shake it twice
pause it rip and burn matches are trash
in general
i think they're classy they're evidence
of a of a distinguished gentleman what
do you bear grylls
they're nice wooden ones whose role i
used i've rolled with those for sure
though
it was bear grylls the lightest things
with the magnifying glass did you ever
you ever let a cigarette with the with
the matchy the long matches for the
fireplace
yeah the door of flame jones yeah for
sure no not a door
not a starter log
[Laughter]
the grill lighters are tough have you
ever been out somewhere and someone had
your grill light or like they had it in
the car or something
it's on the ready and my parents fought
in the smoking lounge at park
what i'm saying at the house is fine
because there's a grill close but i've
had like gotten buddies cars where i'm
like
they hit you with the [ __ ] red grill
lights from the front yeah
what the [ __ ] is this thing all right
let's do one more here
uh let's do two more this one's actually
from the facebook group it's just a
[ __ ] home run real quick have you
ever attended an oz fest
get out of here no ice fest no warp tour
no lollapalooza no woodstock t-bones had
a dual wharf tour at some point
first concert warped tour 2003 charlotte
north carolina dropkick murphy's andrew
w.k
less than jake [ __ ] afi stunk
watch davey havoc hitting the nuts with
the shoe one of the best things i've
ever seen in my entire [ __ ] life i
didn't know one [ __ ] person you said
there
one name um not one
how many monster any of your drinks did
you have a couple red bulls
let me tell you what those were all
right i hate a monster love a sugary red
bull though love me too buddy i love you
you are kids with spirits on that love a
sugar-free red bull
yeah they're not the they're not the
enemy that people
made them out to be because let me tell
you something red bull hits you slower
than coffee
and i think they're better for you okay
yeah i don't know i don't have the uh
scientific research to back it up i'm
not a big
guy you ever you ever crush a red bull
when you're thirsty dude red bull's my
favorite soda
so put it in my cereal
with the homies the homies i like my
soda with my hair
i like my red sugar-free red bull sodas
with the homies
i would like to see how long toby could
like spit out a spiel
but she was pretty close to the warped
tour where it's all his lingo
you know what i mean yeah i had a red
bull with the homies at the warp tour
with andrew
we did an ollie in a bubble butter
though i don't know if ollie's his lingo
but
no whatever all right let's uh this is
the last one
um this is from alessandro alessandro
first time question here thank you buddy
ever in a movie from a red box
[Laughter]
that my friends is what i call a home
run redbox is
was and always will be trash how do you
get it back in there
i don't know i've done it one time keep
it i think you keep those
no no no no no you return them i did it
one time
i remember i was living my buddy had run
into townhouse in bucks county like
right after college
we had our first jobs it was like a
sunday night late
and we were like oh let's get a movie or
something so he's like let's go to red
bot and to me i'm like what the [ __ ] is
it what are we doing
going to a vending machine outside of
7-eleven and sure [ __ ] we were there and
it gives you a [ __ ] move and i
remember then i'm like
i don't know what this is it seems
pretty convenient but i want no parts of
it and i will not be a redbox family
i've never said this out loud okay but
it's something that i still think of to
this day
causes always trying to get pringles out
of it
causes me an insane amount of anxiety
and it's it's why sometimes i
snap in certain situations but for some
reason
the 7-eleven by my house had
like a video vending machine this was
mid 80s
really i don't know why early 84 85
where you had the you go in you you you
it's in a vending machine
all right and you saw the movie you
pressed it came out
but you had to have this card it had to
be like with the company or whatever
like you gotta have this card that you
put money
on but we didn't know that so it was me
and my dad
[ __ ] long week of work he's in his
uniform stuff like that
now i'm like movie movie movie
so he takes me over there and we spend
like an
i i mean honestly an hour looking at
movies
trying to figure out which one we want
and all at the machine
ultimate how many movies could have been
in there it was like literally the size
of like the wall
it was like like the entire candy aisle
okay this machine was there
okay it was either like west coast was
closed or blockbuster
yet and um i remember like at one point
my friend's mom was there she's like
what are you guys doing we're looking
for a movie or something like that
but we when we went to go get the movie
we found out that we had to have this
special car
that you didn't have and for some reason
i felt so embarrassed
i don't know i just felt like a loser
yeah then i you know i like i
i just felt terrible you know the fact
that my dad was with me was like even
worse
it was it's like and it's crazy but it's
like one of those things i still think
about to this day
sure and never would i [ __ ] go to a
red box
because of that yeah i look at them and
i'm like you're not [ __ ] getting me
twice yeah you're not going to get me
today
video movie vending machine not me and
my old man
[ __ ] you he's not happy a move that i
guarantee a listener has done
is you get a red box you scan it you
scan the disk
and then you print off the thing that
has like the qr code that's
the machine scans you put it back in you
put that slip of paper
back in the case put it back in the red
box get a [ __ ] video game or a flick
for a dollar
i i a couple times i got a thing out of
red box and it was just a slip of paper
and i was like you [ __ ] oh yeah
all right why would it be a slit of
paper because
it had like they have like a barcode on
there that the machine scans that knows
what's in the machine oh they put it
back in the case
yeah oh you pieces of [ __ ] yeah oh i'd
[ __ ] smash the machine if that
happened
especially after the childhood drama i
just i just sure confessed to you
sure there was things are trash there
was the trashiest thing my town had was
there was a
uh bait machine like a bait vending
machine
yeah with live bait yeah because the
like
who feeds the worms what do you mean who
feeds the worms how do they stay alive
they stay alive and like the dirt that
they're in what about what about like
fresh air and stuff
i think there's holes in the thing i
mean it's not like a hermetically sealed
[ __ ] vending machine this guy's
buying dead worms
you ain't going to catch anything catch
a cold
but uh yeah we used to go to that
because like the place didn't want it
the place is so big i think his name was
robinsons or something
tackle like a gun and tackle store they
weren't open because people would go
fishing at like [ __ ]
6 a.m or whatever and they would go like
yeah so they just had a
bait vending machine i remember thinking
that was i remember thinking that was
the coolest thing in the world dude i'd
be like yo dad can we stop and get some
night crawlers let's go
just for the fun of it yeah needs and
gibby needs a new pet i didn't [ __ ] with
night crawlers
big night crawler guy i think i said
this one time i'm close to a snake
for the fully so i don't like that
your dad's got a pair of night crawlers
there's that weird band-aid on them yeah
yeah
yeah
you hook them real good oh get it in
there it's got the rough little field
yeah no thank you i think i talked about
and then we got to get out of i talked
about it one time we went up the
mountains
and for like a fishing trip we was like
big like freshwater like
rivers and lakes and stuff like that's
why we did a lot we went up to the
mountains
and we were like staying on this lake
and we took the hose and at night we
sprayed the outside
backyard dirt slugs to get the worms to
come out
because they move in the rain so then
they all came out and we went and picked
up the [ __ ] worms
what the [ __ ] i think we only found like
two by the way
ever put salt on a slug yeah i've done
that
that's [ __ ] up yeah that's like war
crimes that's
real bad all right let's wrap it up salt
and slugs
yeah you gotta yeah you're you're not
stopping there salt and slugs and drawn
out worms yeah
next thing you know you're freezing
grannies
you got anything for him kip that's it
baby uh please make sure you review
subscribe
the whole nine yards itunes patreon uh
youtube i'm
kevin ryan comedy on all social media
also please follow the ru garbage pages
on
instagram and twitter and guys honestly
again thank you
so [ __ ] much from the bottom of the
bottom of my heart it's the patreon
[ __ ] nashville we just hit a big
milestone on patreon this week thank you
so much for that thank you so much
for everybody coming out it means
literally the [ __ ] world to us i feel
corny because i keep saying that but
it's so funny
we don't mean to throw it down thank you
so much appreciate it yeah and get those
[ __ ] ticks gang
ac is gonna sell out we're already like
70. it's not for another [ __ ] two
months and it's like seven five percent
full so get those [ __ ] ticks summer
or garbage [ __ ] come see us we love
you
peace